bonjour je les salue casimir tu as vu
mes nouveaux jouets ouais alors alors
alors comme on les trouve sur un très
bon très bon dis moi que fait françois
là bas avec les enfants ils jouent au
jeu des mimes au jeu des mines à
formidable tu sais c'est mon ces mots
jeux favoris ah oui une deux une deux ou
deux mais qu'est ce que tu fais casimir
des exercices d'assouplissement toit
souple y croit mais assouplir mes
muscles un grand mime doit toujours
avoir les muscles très souple une de bon
je suis prêt à givet mairie casimir tu
appelles regarder mes jouets voit
lorsqu'on prend pas personne ne
s'intéresse à mes nouveaux jouets
mécaniques
bonjour françois bonjour les enfants
dont jean casimir
je voudrais bien faire un mime dit et
bien demande à jean-marc puisque c'est
son tour ah bon jean marc tu veux bien
mais c'est ta place et casimir à
remercie jean marc
bon alors attention vous êtes prêts très
bien on va y aller ou chez vous regardez
bien ce que fait casimir essayer de
deviner ce que représentent ces 1000
alors on y va
[Musique]
vous avez une idée sur ce qu'il est en
train de mimer
moi je vois pas écouté on va lui
demander les demandes et casimir quasi
mais qu'est-ce que je tu nous dire ce
qui représente tomine mais rien j'étais
en train de réfléchir à ce que je
pourrais bien me met alors c'était le
mime du mime qui ne trouvent pas de mine
traquant des attardés ça y est j'en ai
trouvé un regard du bien essayé de
dominer voilà chez vous les enfants vous
regardez bien ce que fait casimir pour
qui
et des réponses c'est terminé 15e et
ouais ils vous invitent trouverez les
réponses que vous proposez à casimir tu
avais dit quelque chose
outil un potier non alors de nous la
réponse quasi personne à trouver et bien
c'est un sage qui me up et qui trouve à
un ordre d'autruche et ils croient que
c'est une noix de coco alors il le
caceis en met partout
weeks alliages devrait en trouver un
autre attend l'équipe voilà regardez
bien de ce que chaque geste très
important
peut-être on va lui demander c'est ainsi
christ non qu'est ce que c'est la somme
ne trouve non pas oui voilà c'est un
monsieur qui a une voiture
il ferme la porte puis l'ami sa voiture
dans une descente et il a oublié de
serrer le frein à main
oh là là c'est toute une histoire ça a
été aisé mais c'est difficile à trouver
et rend compliqué bon alors je vais
peut-être en un peu plus sans chercher
un plus simples ont été les enfants et
avec ma famille avec moi j'arriverais
jelly défense
bon c'est vrai ils sont très bons n'est
ce pas quel est celui qui prépare pour
cette vitesse dans les couches très
drôle d'ironie désolé de l'état leur
chère tu sais tout à l'heure j'étais
très triste parce que personne ne
s'intéressait à les jouer
alors j'ai réfléchi et je me suis dit
l'intérêt des vielles mécaniques
c'était d'être mécanique alors vraiment
julie coin fond tu as des idées elles
sont géniales ne commentera moi c'est
très sérieux alors je les ai faits
marché est maintenant toujours s'y
intéresse
je suis sûr que je vais en vente
beaucoup tu m'en donnes une idée
formidable je vais gagner beaucoup
d'argent
j'ai justement besoin de claudie francs
pour renouveler ma provision de
gloubiboulga que battus pendant que les
aimer ça c'est une surprise isaac
[Musique]
là encore une dernière
ça y est c'est parfait bon bah ça y est
allé demander les bougies venaient
acheter des belles bougies d'amender les
belles bougies
bon allez voir mes bougies mais casimir
qu'est ce que tu fais là je suis pour
une bête question c'est vraiment une
bête question il paraît évident que ce
soit en train de vendre des bougies oui
mais je m'en suis aperçu figure toi
seulement pourquoi les as-tu allumé mais
pour montrer comment elles marchent que
tu ne vas pas pouvoir les vendre
et pourquoi tu me disais le contraire
tout à l'heure en fin mai enfin casimir
ça n'a aucun rapport
quand je fais marcher mes jouets
mécaniques je ne les ai pas si tu fais
brûler t bougies elles ne pourront plus
servir à rien mais c'est pourtant le
seul moyen pour montrer aux acheteurs si
elles marchent bien ou pas mais pas des
bougies
ah bon alors tu crois que je ne vais pas
réussir à a gagné les différents dont
j'ai besoin pour mon gloubiboulga a
sûrement pas très cool je vais essayer
quand même un laisse moi allez
demandaient les balles bougies y acheter
des bougies
[Musique]
bodji demandé mes bougies
vous voulez des bougies non elles sont
pas chères jean-marc non géval elle
reste à casimir y en a pour les bougies
et tu n'as rien vendu la raison jolie
j'aurais vraiment pas dû qu'à une
démonstration
bonjour ma très chère julie bonjour mais
c est stable que se passe-t-il avec
second casimir rien rien du tout
monsieur du snob aller voir là bas si
j'y suis ok fait voir quelle merveille
auquel poésie de couleur quelle matière
ans j'aimerais bien connaitre d'artiste
génial que créer une oeuvre aussi
sublime que celle là ça vous paie un
fini mans et bien ça c'est à vendre
merveilleux sens françois non 110 à 117
un peu cher et bien il faut 100 francs
pour le génial artiste c'est à dire moi
et 10 francs pour ma réserve de
gloubiboulga re
à